[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avait
clamé côté thibault dogues ont gentiment
auriol est notre invité cette semaine et
christian jacob bonjourbonjour député de
seine-et-marne vous êtes président du
groupe l'est républicain l'assemblée
nationale merci d'être avec nous cette
semaine et dans l'actualité
parlementaire il ya d'abord ce marathon
à l'assemblée nationale 14 heures de
débats sur les thèmes du grand débat
national
les députés ont pu faire leurs
propositions mais le gouvernement lui
réservent les siennes
de quoi susciter les critiques sur
l'utilité de cet exercice
dans le même temps senna ce sont les
ministres responsables du grand débat
qui ont été auditionnées et parmi les
thèmes évoqués à l'assemblée il y avait
d'abord la fiscalité le gouvernement a
cherché à prévenir les déceptions il n'y
aura pas de big bang fiscal a expliqué
bruno le maire
le groupe les républicains défendent et
lui ses propositions en la matière jeudi
dans l'hémicycle elles ont été rejetées
par la majorité que veut faire le
gouvernement sur la réforme des
institutions sur ce point aussi son
discours est resté sibyllin l'exécutif
paraît hésiter en particulier sur la
prise en compte ou non du vote blanc
enfin une audition importante au sénat
celle du nouveau préfet de police de
paris didier lallement a détaillé le
dispositif renforcé déployés après les
dysfonctionnements constatés lors des
violences du 16 mars à paris et on
commence avec le grand débat national
qui s'est donc invité au parlement cette
semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux après midi et deux soirées de
débats et malgré tout une impression de
rendez vous manqués l'assemblée
nationale a longuement débattu des
quatre thèmes du grand débat cette
semaine
l'idée était de permettre aux députés de
faire entendre leurs propositions
problème le gouvernement n'avait pas
d'annoncé à faire
et faute d'enjeu à l'exercice a été
boudé par une partie des députés
le gouvernement a tenté de se justifier
ils étaient venus écouter leur des
annonces viendra ensuite a expliqué le
ministre de l'ecologie françois de rugy
ont l'écoutent je veux dire monsieur
jacob je vous réponds très concrètement
très calmement
vous le savez parfaitement bien mais
vous essayez évidemment de sans doute de
d'animer un peu le débat je vais le
prendre comme cela mais vous savez très
bien que nous respectons les différentes
étapes donc le gouvernement moi en tant
que ministre je ne vais pas aujourd'hui
faire des propositions alors qu' il y à
une restitution qui doit voir le 8 avril
christian jacob on a entendu le ministre
vous répondre vous regrettiez que le
gouvernement ne soient pas venus avec
des propositions c'était un débat pour
rien c'est une grande mascarade
tout ça ne ressemble à l'assemblée
nationale comme le sénat ça n'est pas à
une salle des fêtes un gymnase
on est en fait la loi c'est à dire que
après depuis le temps que dure ce débat
en fait quand on parle de débat
d'ailleurs ses monologues successifs du
président de la république c'est plutôt
sale la réalité des choses
on est en droit d'attendre des
propositions et qu'il y ait sur la table
un texte c'est comme ça que l'assemblée
fonctionne c'est à dire le gouvernement
et initiatives mais un texte et à partir
de là et bien on travaille dessus en
commission avec des amendements des
propositions et puis amendement par
amendement on vote article après article
et c'est comme ça que se construit la
loi dont ça c'est ce qui se fait dans
95% des cas il ya une autre possibilité
celle où l'opposition mais une
proposition de loi sur la table donc
nous l'avons fait et nous l'avons fait
jeudi
mais là aussi le gouvernement refuse la
discussion c'est à dire si ça vient de
l'opposition donc c'est refusé avant
même qu'il y ait débat
d'ailleurs vous avez bien noté qu'il y
avait pas de débat c'est une succession
de monologues d'intervention puisque
forme qui empêchait la forme et ses
surnoms enfin la forme et le fond mais
c'est surtout de ne pas avoir mis une
proposition sur la table en disant voilà
après cinq mois de crise voilà ce que
l'on met sur la table
et puis chaque groupe politique bat
essaye de corriger le texte par voie
d'amendement mais mais mais là c'est
succession de monologues pourront rien
cirque on a bloqué une semaine complète
puisque cette semaine a été rythmée sur
ce sujet et on remet ça la semaine
prochaine comme s'ils savaient pas été
suffisant mais résultat on a vu c'est
vrai cette image dans l'hémicycle aux
trois quarts vide pendant deux jours
est-ce qu'au moment où il ya un climat
d' antiparlementarisme ce n'est pas
donné le bâton pour se faire battre
oui mais enfin l'assemblée est là pour
travailler là ça sert à quoi on n'est
pas obligé de tomber dans tous les
pièges du côté on n'est pas là on vous
c'est un piège cdh s'est passé
c'est inutile a faim c'est pas inutile
pour le gouvernement puisque l'objectif
on le connaît bien c'est de faire durer
et donc on fait du rieur disant voyez on
a écouté tout le monde on a consulté
tout le monde mais si vraiment le
gouvernement était dans dans cet état
d'esprit à ce moment là lorsque nous
faisons une proposition de loi jeudi
mais comme nous l'avons fait à d'autres
occasions dans les niches parlementaires
et bien le gouvernement accepte de
rentrer dans le débat il nous contrer
argument contre argument mais là ça
n'est même pas le cas ça vient de vous
donc hors de question d'en discuter
on fait une motion procédure et on vous
renvoie dans vos 18 mètres non va on va
revenir sur votre proposition dans un
petit peu plus tard dans l'émission mais
d'abord autre type d'exercice 1 au sénat
sur ce grand débat puisque les sénateurs
ont choisi d'auditionner les deux
ministres en charge du grand débat
emmanuelle wargon et sébastien lecornu
c'était jeudi matin 1h30 des changes et
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
cette audition c'est un échange entre
eux le sénateur philippe dominati et le
ministre à sébastien lecornu à propos du
coût de ce grand débat je voudrais
connaître le coût réel
le coût réel de ce débat pour l'état et
pas le coût caché que l'on découvrira
peut-être plus tard nous avions estimé
le coût global entre 10 et 15 millions
d'euros
on va être globalement à 12 millions
d'euros les débats sur le coût du grand
débat me semble intéressant mais
justement ils sont à mettre en
perspective de ce que coûte la
démocratie et pour jean jacob un mot sur
ce qu'on vient d'entendre le coût de ce
grand débat 12 millions d'euros cela
vous choque
12 millions d'euros pour servir ses
dires le la notoriété en quelque sorte
du président de la république parce que
c'est une mise en scène du président de
la république ces débats regardez ce
serait amusant de faire une compilation
de chacun des débats des reprises
médiatique
c'est une mise en scène de sa personne
donc voilà bon la république a déposé 12
millions pour que le président de la
république puisse se met se met en scène
ce que le même président et les mêmes
ministres n'hésitent pas à considérer
qu'il ya trop d'élus trop payés et
qu'ils ne font pas bien leur travail là
on y va et on est vraiment se draper
dans la vertu redisant mais comment tout
ça coûte très cher mais là le président
de la république non faut soigner sa
mise en scène est là et on n'ajoute pas
ça j'imagine que n'a pas été
comptabilisé 2
la mobilisation des forces de sécurité
c'est quand même invraisemblable c'est à
dire que à chaque fois on compte par
centaines les policiers les gendarmes
qui sont mobilisés pour que le président
de la république puisse aller délivrer
son discours est simple vous dit
plusieurs vignettes il ya un coût caché
2 millions ce n'est pas le bon chiffre
je sais pas je n'ai pas d'éléments pour
le contester donc je peux faire un
procès d'intention mais la réalité c'est
que je n'en sais rien qu'est-ce qui
s'intéresseront fait le bilan il ya un
million et demi de citoyens qui ont
participé à ce débat seize mille cahiers
de doléances 10000 réunion est ce que ce
n'est quand même pas un succès ce grand
débat oui c'est important je crois du
corps électoral à peine vous êtes un
échec
je pense que si on avait des élus ancré
sur le territoire ce qui est d'ailleurs
un des problèmes pour les parlementaires
en marche qui n'ont pas cet ancrage
territorial et d'ailleurs on a supprimé
c'est assez amusant le comportement à
l'égard des mères vont ça vous a pas
échappé
dans un premier temps les maires ont été
accusés de tous les maux d'organiser
j'irai ddd des bastions des bastions
locaux de vivre sur leur pré carré etc
et puis après d'un seul coup quand on a
vu qu effectivement que l'opinion
publique elle soutient les les maires
dont revirement les mères étaient
devenus des gens formidables de
proximité qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
soigner
entre temps on avait fait l'opération
balances ton mer mené par monsieur
darmanin bon tout ça n'est pas très
n'est pas très sérieux et et un objectif
gagner du temps et mettre en scène le
président de la république le premier
ministre à s'exprimer désormais devant
l'assemblée mardi le sénat mercredi sur
les conclusions du grand débat qu'en
attendez vous ben rien puisque le
premier ministre a dénoncé lui-même je
referai pas d'annonce donc on va être
encore dans un débat pour rien puisque
une fois de plus il va en tirer les
conclusions mais sans faire de
propositions puisque la mise en scène là
aussi c'est le président de la
république
on va encore sans doute ça va sans doute
encore coûté beaucoup d'argent pour
soigner sa mise en scène pour ce qu'il
puisse faire ses effets d'annoncé
puisque les ministres sont interdits
d'annoncés de propositions concrètes
c'était d'ailleurs assez affligeant de
on va rentrer de les voir
là dans l'hémicycle tête baissée sur
leur smartphone à écouter attendre
puisque interdit de voir entrer dans le
fond des sujets justement avec d'abord
celui sur la fiscalité ce débat sur la
fiscalité les dépenses publiques il
s'est déroulé mardi soir à l'assemblée
nationale le gouvernement là encore à
avancer masqué si l'exécutif a bien pris
le pouls du ras-le-bol fiscale relayée
par de nombreux français
il exclut tout big bang en la matière
résumé des débats avec alice go grégoire
l'heure n'est pas encore aux
propositions lors du débat sur la
fiscalité aucune annonce concrète n'a
été faite par le gouvernement mais à
l'évidence l'exécutif maintient le cap
bruno le maire l'a répété il est
favorable à une baisse des impôts mais
sous conditions seule la dépense
publique
bc doit nous permettre de financer cette
baisse d'impôts de son côté le ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics et a
confirmé la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation pour l'ensemble des
contribuables
nous avons évidemment à accomplir la
promesse du président de la république
puis l'engagement du président de la
république à la fin de l'année 2010
celle de la suppression à 100 % de la
taxe d'habitation sans les résidences
secondaires
d'ici la fin du quinquennat du président
de la république c'est à dire d'ici de
l'année budgétaire 2020 deux autres
thématiques abordées la remise à plat
des niches fiscales
gérald darmanin a évoqué la possibilité
d'évaluer leur efficacité
donc si le parlement ici le plf fait un
travail sur lequel bercy est tout à fait
prêt à couvrir tous les livres
d'évaluation des niches
nous sommes tout à fait disposés à ce
que la justice fiscale soit au rendez
vous rétablir lisf plus de justice
fiscale tout au long de la séance elle
les différents groupes d'opposition
n'ont pas manqué de faire des
propositions
mardi prochain le premier ministre sera
très attendu sur ces questions lors de
son discours à l'assemblée nationale
alors question jacob le midi pas de big
bang fiscal les français risquent d'être
déçus ce qu'est ce que je relève de deux
phrases qui sont assez intéressante
d'une part dire le gouvernement
maintient le cap
c'est quand même assez surprenant de
dire on écoute on est à l'écouté des
français on est même allé coûte de l'eau
de l'opposition etc mais de toute façon
on maintient le cap donc fermer le ban
il y aura aucun changement
là c'est croustillant deuxième élément
assez croustillant aussi la déclaration
de monsieur darmanin qui nous annonce la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
le prochain quinquennat
moi je vous garantis que je peux prendre
beaucoup d'engagement effectivement pour
le prochain quinquennat ou celui encore
après demain on rase gratis mais demain
aujourd'hui le gouvernement sans quoi
mais a repris le constat du raz le bol
fiscale et prévoit sans doute d'abaisser
la pression fiscale pour une partie des
français notamment les classes moyennes
inférieures c'est une bonne nouvelle sur
ce point vous y croyez bah écoutez la
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que la
démonstration n'est elle n'a pas été
fait
à ce stade on vient de battre tous les
records sur des prélèvements
obligatoires on a passé pour la première
fois de notre histoire la barre des 45 %
de prélèvements obligatoires
ce gouvernement si vous prenez
aujourd'hui les critères économiques qui
sont intéressants celui de montant de la
dette publique la dépense publique
le montant de la dette le déficit et la
balance commerciale
ces quatre points sont assez riches
d'enseignement parce que la dépense
publique
on voit effectivement si l'état continue
a dit à des pans à dépenser plus que ce
qu'il ne gagne si vous prenez
l'endettement on sait que l'endettement
d'aujourd'hui ce sont les impôts de
demain
le taux des prélèvements obligatoires et
la balance les résultats de la balance
commerciale qui est soit un élément
important de compétitivité de nos
entreprises comment on va chercher des
points de croissance extérieure sur ces
quatre critères macron c'est hollande en
pire
parce que à chaque fois depuis deux ans
il a aggravé la situation
on a augmenté la dette de manière très
importante
depuis deux ans on a augmenté les
dépenses publiques
les prélèvements obligatoires ont
augmenté et la balance commerciale s'est
totalement dégradée donc deux ans et
c'est important au bout de deux ans on
peut commencer à regarder surtout
d'ailleurs si on voulait très objectif
ça fait pas deux ans ça fait sept ans en
réalité que le président de la
république est impliqué dans la
politique économique puisqu'il a été
d'abord le conseiller de françois de
françois hollande il a été ensuite sur
ministre de l'économie des finances et
les maintenant président de la
république
et depuis qu'il est là les deux ans
vraiment il a toutes les manettes
la situation se dégrade totalement par
rapport à ce qu'elle était sous alan
donc macron sur le plan économique c'est
hollande en pire malgré tout s'il y
avait une baisse de la pression fiscale
par exemple une sur un allègement des
deux premières tranches de l'impôt sur
le revenu comme le propose le groupe la
république en marche vous le soutiendrez
y ait dans la baisse du taux de l'impôt
sur le revenu ça c'est la proposition
que nous nous nous avons fait moi sur le
reste j'attends de voir mais on a eu
tellement d'entourloupe surtout voyez on
est aujourd'hui on est au mois deux mois
d'avril avec un budget totalement
insincère d'ailleurs c'était souligné
pas par moi mais par la cour des comptes
qui soucie souli l'insincérité c'est à
dire qu'on fait des annonces budgétaires
qui ne sont pas financés par exemple la
taxe d'habitation
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas comment elle
est financée donc de fait ça se traduit
par des augmentations de dette donc de
l'impôt demain et est ce qui m'a amené
d'ailleurs à le dire un moment dans le
débat avec le ministre du budget nous
avons une dette qui augmente donc un
ministre qui a menti en permanence en
nous expliquant mais la charge de la
dette le sujet c'est pas celui là
la charge de la dette à l'ailier
d'ailleurs aux taux d'intérêt la réalité
c'est que la dette augmente depuis que
monsieur macro et là par rapport à ce
qu'était la situation sous allende
alors on va parler de votre proposition
de loi christian jacob puisqu'on parle
de fiscalité votre groupe défendrait une
proposition de loi pour rendre aux
français
plusieurs milliards de pouvoir d'achat
le texte proposait notamment de revenir
sur la hausse de la csg pour les
retraités et la réindexation de leur
retraite des revendications portées par
de nombreux gilet jaune mais sans sou
grande surprise il a été repoussé par le
gouvernement et la majorité le gua
suppression de la hausse de la csg ré
indexation des pensions de retraite
la proposition de loi portée par les
républicains avait comme objectif de
rétablir le pouvoir d'achat des français
le manque de dimension humaine dans vos
réformes a surtout réveiller chez nos
concitoyens un sentiment d'injustice
jamais vraiment dormir justice sociale
territoriale injustice entre les
générations
le gouvernement pointe l'incohérence du
financement de toutes ces mesures
votre proposition de loi estimé
aujourd'hui à 10 milliards d'euros selon
vous quasiment 10 est en réalité cette
proposition de loi s'apparente davantage
à une critique qu'à une véritable
proposition
cette critique la majorité ne l'entend
pas elle accuse un texte irresponsable
et démagogique
ce texte je les rebaptiser pjl d'orgue
comme demain on rase gratis
mais notre majorité n'a pas attendu
votre proposition de loi pour renforcer
le pouvoir de choix à gauche et la
proposition de loi n'a également pas
convaincu ce qui nous ennuie dans votre
ppl c'est la manière dont vous financer
ces mesures c'est à dire par des coupes
massives entre 10 et 20 milliards
d'euros dans les dépenses publiques et
donc dans les services publics une
mention de renvoi en commission a été
voté à 90 voix pour contre 54 aucun
article n'a donc été examinées christian
jacob l'appel a donc été à rejeter vous
ne le disais tout à l'heure on a
l'impression que l'opposition n'ait pas
écouté par ce gouvernement
elle n'a pas en réalité elle n'a pas été
rejetée il n'y a pas eu de débat c'est
ça qui est qui qui est assez
invraisemblable et examens
le groupe parlementaire qui est l'autre
celui des républicains que les
spectateurs comprennent bien c'est le
premier groupe d'opposition nous avons
cent quatre députés c'est que plus que
tous les autres groupes d'opposition et
nous avons dans le règlement de notre
assemblée d'ailleurs dans la
constitution la possibilité trois fois
par an de présenter ce qu'on appelle une
journée de niche parlementaire donc on
présente des projets de loi alors
qu'habituellement les propositions de
loi sont présentés par la majorité ou
projet de loi ce qui est d'ailleurs la
quasi unanimité ou très généralement
projet de loi présenté par le par le
gouvernement donc il y a trois jours où
on peux nous présenter et là par une
motion de procédure
la majorité refuse qu'il y ait le débat
c'est à dire que nous nous présentons un
projet une proposition de loin avec
différentes mesures sur lesquelles on va
peut-être revenir et 10 rebonds débat on
peut en débattre
article par article argument contre
argument non ils mettent une motion de
procédure
on en débat pour trois jours par an tout
le reste de l'année c'est la majorité
qui est qui qui a la maîtrise de l'ordre
du jour est là pour cette journée au
moins qu'on en débatte article par
article
mais même ça c'est refuser vous êtes
vous surpris de la tournure des
relations entre l'exécutif et le
parlement aujourd'hui
ah oui il ya une vraie dérive
institutionnelle jamais bon j'ai pas
beaucoup de sympathie pour monsieur
monsieur hollande mais mais on est dans
une situation qu'on n'a jamais connu
c'est à dire d'un mépris total des élus
d'une manière générale et des
parlementaires en particulier avec un
parlement qui en permanence méprisé
humilié on l'a vu sur la commission
enquête sur cette affaire
triste affaire benalla macron la manière
dont s'était bloqué le débat était
interdit à l'assemblée heureusement que
le sénat a fait cent ans a fait son
travail l'a à nouveau
j'avais demandé une commission denquête
sur ce qui s'est passé le 16 mars avec
des violences inouïes avec le limogeage
d'un préfet de police c'est pas quelque
chose d'anodin
le limogeage de hauts fonctionnaires de
police ça n'est pas anodin et j'ai
proposé même au président de l'assemblée
nationale en disant écoutez la
commission denquête moi je ne demande
pas la préside et je demande pas à ce
que ce soit les républicains mais
faisons là avec l'ensemble des groupes
et que le président de l'assemblée
nationale lui même la président ça ne
posait aucun problème mais simplement je
considère qu'il ya un rôle qui est celui
de l'assemblée qui a le pouvoir de
contrôler et de pouvoir exercer son
pouvoir de contrôle pour vérifier
comment les choses se sont se sont
passées les hordes ont ils été donnée
pas donné appliquée par qui comment
pourquoi cette transparence à les
refuser et la sueur situation si grave
que celle nous vivons depuis cinq mois
nous mettons sur la table des
propositions avec des mesures très
claires en matière de pouvoir d'achat
eh bien ça on nous refuse même le droit
d'en parler c'est à dire aux 10 ans
circulent et de toute façon ça vient des
républicains on prend même pas le temps
d'en parler on met deux motions de
procédure et on dégage tous
un mot sur le fond vous financer ces 10
à 17 milliards de pouvoir d'achat rendu
aux français par des que coûteraient ces
baisses d'impôts via une baisse des
dépenses publiques mais c'est autant
d'argent qui n'iraient pas au
désendettement pour le coup vous nous en
parliez tout à l'heure
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là un problème il
y a eu deux parties c'est à dire qu'il
ya une partie effectivement majeur dans
ce cadre là après bon là on en est pas
un programme de gouvernement sur le
programme de gouvernement viendra le
temps où effectivement il ya une part
sur le désendettement
ce que nous faisons c'est que nous
finançons d'abord ces mesures les
mesures qu'on annonce c'est se financent
par une baisse des dépenses publiques
donc ça passe par d'abord une réforme de
la réforme des retraites ça passe aussi
par une réforme de la fonction publique
on considère qu'il faut diminuer le
nombre de postes c'est à dire en
compensant avec une augmentation du
temps de travail et une augmentation du
paiement c'est à dire des fonctionnaires
mieux payés
travaillant davantage qui nous permet de
gagner des postes et de faire des
économies
et puis d'autres mesures c'est la remise
en cause de l'aide médicale d'état et un
certain nombre d'autres points qui nous
permettent de financer cela mais lorsque
viendra le temps de présenter un
programme de gouvernement il y
effectivement vous avez raison une
partie des dépenses publiques qui seront
affectés à la au désendettement
allez vous parler des violences du 16
mars un creux dit didier lallement le
nouveau préfet de police de paris et est
auditionné au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
auditionné donc le nouveau préfet de
police de paris sur les violences qui
ont eu lieu à paris le 16 mars il
n'était pas en fonction
ce jour là puisqu'il a succédé à michel
delpech limogé suite à ces événements
mais d'idées l'allemand a évoqué le
dépit des forces de l'ordre à l'issue de
cette journée et dit avoir tiré les
leçons en matière de maintien de l'ordre
résumé de cette audition samia de chair
le 16 mars dernier certaines unités
assiste immobile aux violences sur les
champs elysées elles n'ont tout
simplement pas reçu l'ordre d'agir
le gouvernement promet alors une plus
grande sévérité et nomme un nouveau
préfet de police didier lallement
auditionné mercredi par les sénateurs il
a présenté la nouvelle feuille de route
désormais chaque unité se verra
attribuer une mission sur un périmètre
précis pour plus d'autonomie sur le
terrain vous avez la mission et vous
l'avez dans ce périmètre géographe et
sert qu'on n'attende pas l'ordre de la
salle pour agir puisqu'on sait que la
mission doit s'effectuer dans telle zone
géographique plus autonome
les forces de l'ordre seront aussi plus
mobile elles seront progressivement
équipés de véhicules légers type de roue
nous avons en face de nous des gens
extrêmement mobile extrêmement mobiles
très rapide qui change de rue or nous
notre système il est basé sur des forces
qui embarquent dans des cars l'écart
roulent les gens les forces des barques
vous voyez bien que quoi qu'on fasse
dans un système comme ça ma la
manifestation mobile elle sera déjà
trois rues plus tard un dispositif qui
inquiète certains sénateurs
car il existe déjà des policiers à moto
les brigades de répression contre les
actions violentes
très contesté ces brigades ressemblent
comme des soeurs jumelles aux voltigeurs
qui ont été mises en cause dans la mort
de malik oussékine et qui ont été
dissous en 1986 une petite différence
technique
les voltigeurs étaient sur des engins
légers nous on transporte nos gars c'est
des équipages qui font de 100 kg on les
transporte des engins de 9 centimètres
cubes je suis monté sur les motos
franchement si vous arrivez à tenir une
matraque sur un engin comme ça avec les
25 et on a franchement chapeau
autre inquiétude des sénateurs
l'utilisation des lanceurs de balles de
défense responsable de graves
les sur didier lallement a confirmé le
maintien de leur utilisation lors des
prochaines manifestations
christian jacob entre la nomination d'un
nouveau préfet de police et une nouvelle
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre est ce
que vous pensez que désormais il y aura
plus de violence dans les nouvelles
manifestations
alors ouais là le sujet on essaye de
nous expliquer qu'en changeant préfet de
police tout va bien aller fournier le
sujet c'est pas celui du préfet de
police c'est celui de la compétence du
ministre de l'intérieur et du premier
ministre à réagir face à ces actes de
violence parce que ce même préfet de
police quand il était en postant en
aquitaine sauf erreur de ma part il ya
eu aussi des violences et des dérapages
scandaleux à bordeaux et à toulouse donc
le sujet ça n'est pas le préfet de
police
mais c'est celui qui lui donnent les
ordres et donc c'était l'incapacité de
réaction d'un ministre de l'intérieur le
sujet leur habilité c'est christophe
castaner très clairement un mot pour
finir sur la censure du conseil
constitutionnel concernant la loi
anti-casseurs censure partielle mais
censure de l'article phare celui
permettant à des préfets de procéder à
des interdictions administratives de
manifester est ce que vous regrettez
cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel
oui mais elle est d'abord le résultat de
l'hypocrisie du président de la
république qui présente un texte au
parlement qui le fait voter par sa
majorité et qui immédiatement le défaire
lui-même au conseil constitutionnel on
se doute entré vraisemblablement de la
réaction du conseil constitutionnel donc
c'est d'abord son hypocrisie
il a cherché à faire invalider cette
forme cassette avoir fait mon maître est
clairement temps d c'est vraiment se
moquer du monde en disant je vous
présente une loi je demande à ma joie ma
majorité de voter cette loi
je demande au ministre de lui au
gouvernement de se mobiliser dessus mais
je la défaire immédiatement pour être
sûr que l'article soit soient invalidés
donc maintenant si le président de la
république n'était pas aussi hypocrite
que je le dis et bien j'imagine qu'il va
faire une deuxième délibération et qu'on
peut très bien réécrire ce texte pour
qu'il puisse être validée par le conseil
constitutionnel et que ce soit fait dans
les plus brefs délais des signes de ciel
des relations
écoutez c'est le minimum à faire ou
alors c'est vraiment un comportement
hypocrite
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci
thibault on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]